you want to represent while on the path  jump as a storm  let's call chuckle store t-shirt if you  wear t-shirts you know check them out  discipline equals freedom t-shirts  lightweight hoodies and light and heavy  whatever you need whatever you like and  some other cool stuff rash guards get  that more than one rash guard for  multiple reasons and they don't worry  your kid rash guard stand by to get some  white teeth choco white tea available  travel mugs  women stuff some tank tops and whatnot  have swollen flex get in trucker hats  patches  if you want to represent the path that  we are all on if you listen you know  yeah Jaakko store.com would be like  something kids  [Music]